[Música]
en una medida simbólica el parlamento
europeo declaró a Rusia estado promotor
del terrorismo el mismo día que las
fuerzas de Moscú atacaron un hospital
maternal en sapurilla y mataron a tres
personas en
kiev en Jerusalén dos bombas detonaron
en dos paradas de autobús una de las
explosiones mató un joven de 16 años
ninguna organización ha reivindicado el
ataque pero jamás y la yihat islámica lo
han celebrado además en una redada
israelí en cisjordania un joven
palestino murió tras recibir un disparo
antes de debutar en el mundial de Qatar
los jugadores de la selección alemana
posaron tapándose la boca una protesta
contra la censura de la FIFA que prohíbe
usar el brazalete One Love en defensa de
los Derechos Humanos
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
relativa a la guerra en Ucrania porque
este miércoles Rusia lanzó un ataque
masivo sobre el territorio ucraniano los
misiles rusos mataron a tres personas en
kiev e impactaron sobre un hospital
maternal en zapo sin embargo el
principal objetivo de la ofensiva
continua siendo la infraestructura
energética de hecho este miércoles la
agencia nuclear ucraniana desconectó
tres centrales de la red eléctrica para
evitar daños mayores una de las ciudades
más afectadas por la escasez de
suministros es gerson recientemente
recuperada por las autoridades de kiev
ahí se encuentra nuestra corresponsal
Catalina Gómez Ángel
en los últimos días el gobierno
ucraniano ha estado invitando a la
población de gerson que quiera abandonar
la ciudad a hacerlo y creando las
maneras poniendo no solamente a
disposición las líneas de tren sino
algunos servicios de autobús que los
llevan hasta la capital que fue hasta
las ciudades como Odessa o mico Life sin
embargo estamos en este momento en la
estación de tren de gerson y lo que nos
encontramos es que el número de personas
que intenta dejar la ciudad en las
últimas horas se ha incrementado y ya no
solamente por razones de falta de
infraestructura de escasez de
Electricidad falta de agua sino por el
miedo la guerra se ha acercado a la
gente de gerson antes cuando los
ucranianos atacaban y las fuerzas rusas
estaban aquí Ellos dicen que lo hacían
con mucha precisión las fuerzas
ucranianas pero ahora las fuerzas rusas
están bastante cercas y desde ayer están
atacando con mayor la intensidad la
ciudad lo que ha llevado a que muchas
personas especialmente familias con
niños y personas mayores dejen la ciudad
y precisamente hoy el parlamento europeo
declaró a Rusia como estado promotor del
terrorismo una medida simbólica
solicitada de forma reiterada por el
presidente ucraniano bolodimirsele nos
amplía desde Bruselas nuestra
corresponsal Esther Herrera
con 494 votos a favor y tan solo 58 en
contra la eurocámara ha pedido que se
considera Rusia un estado patrocinador
del terrorismo para los eurodiputados
los ataques indiscriminados contra la
población civil contra infraestructuras
como hospitales y escuelas y así como la
red eléctrica constituyen actos
terroristas y también el crímenes de
guerra se trata de un importante mensaje
político y también es simbólico de apoyo
a Ucrania y a su presidente que pedía un
paso como este de hecho después de esta
votación los servicios informáticos del
parlamento europeo han sufrido un
ciberataque por un grupo Pro kremlin en
cualquier caso nuestro diputados han
pedido También en esta resolución que se
cambie la legislación europea para que
la Unión Europea considere no solo las
organizaciones en las personas
terroristas también a los Estados a la
práctica una de este tipo sería
convertir a Rusia en un estado paria en
que la Unión Europea debería cortar
lazos diplomáticos y económicos algo muy
difícil de poder aplicar a la práctica
de hecho en ningún país del mundo ha
llegado tan lejos ha habido resoluciones
no vinculantes en Estados Unidos como
por ejemplo en el senado en el congreso
pero hasta ahora el secretario de estado
norteamericano Anthony blinken lo ha
rechazado y también votaciones No
vinculantes en parlamentos Como por
ejemplo de los países bálticos o de
Polonia
y en Reino Unido el tribunal supremo
dictaminó que el gobierno de Escocia no
puede convocar un nuevo referendo de
autodeterminación sin la aprobación de
Londres recordemos que en la votación de
2014 el rechazo a la independencia ganó
con un 55% de los votos sin embargo el
gobierno nacionalista escocés considera
que el brexit ha revertido la situación
nuestra corresponsal en territorio
británico Luisa Pulido nos Explica las
alternativas de Escocia para conocer la
opinión de la población si no puede
recurrir al referéndum el reitero
Nicolás toryo la ministra principal
escocesa que el resultado de las
elecciones generales que se podrían
realizar posiblemente en el 2024 si los
nacionalistas escoceses obtienen
nuevamente las mayorías en el parlamento
regional sería entonces un referendo de
facto por supuesto hay muchas preguntas
alrededor de esta posibilidad Nicolás
torjon dijo que los escoceses
encontrarán la manera realizar esa
segunda consulta de manera de manera
legal y dijo que esta no es deseable
sino esencial para evadir el desastre
del brexit como bien mencionadas
insistió en que tiene en los
nacionalistas escocés es el mandato para
realizar esa segunda consulta pero lo
cierto Es que hay muchas todavía
diferencias con Londres en el gobierno
central sobre esa posibilidad se
realizarán esta noche varias
manifestaciones en diferentes ciudades
escocesas para exigir ese segundo
referendo de independencia
en otras noticias dos bombas detonaron
en dos paradas de autobús de Jerusalén
en La hora pico de esta mañana una mató
a un joven de 16 años ninguna
organización ha reivindicado el ataque
pero tanto jamás como la yihat islámica
lo consideraron una respuesta lógica a
la mortífera ocupación israelí de hecho
este año ha sido el más mortífero para
la población Palestina ensis Jordania
ocupada allí precisamente hoy un joven
palestino murió tras recibir un disparo
durante una redada israelí en nebús
y en China estalló la indignación de los
trabajadores de la llamada ciudad iPhone
ante el aumento de casos covid hace unas
semanas la empresa foxcon confinó a más
de 200.000 personas en la planta de este
miércoles los empleados de la mayor
fábrica de iphones del mundo protestaron
contra su situación laboral
manifestaciones inabituales en la mayor
planta de fabricación de iPhone en el
mundo los empleados de la empresa
foxcond en Sant Joan china protestaron
este miércoles exigiendo el respeto de
sus derechos en videos compartidos en
las redes sociales se vieron
manifestantes enfrentándose a personas
con trajes de protección blancos y a los
gases lacrimógenos de la policía
antidisturbios pero el gobierno chino se
niega a comentar los hechos no tengo
conocimiento de la situación que
menciona y esto tampoco es competencia
de asuntos exteriores la empresa
taiwanes es el principal subcontratista
de Apple y emplea a más de 200.000
personas en su planta desde Enjoy al
sufrir una balanza de casos de kois 19
en las últimas semanas centenares de
trabajadores en pánico huyeron a pie la
mayoría de los empleados viven en
dormitorios y han sido confinados en el
sitio que ahora funciona en circuito
cerrado en un comunicado foxcom confirmó
actos de violencia y dijo que trabajara
con los empleados para evitar que
incidentes similares se reproduzcan
china avanza firme con la drástica
política de cero covid impuesta por el
presidente shin-ping según Apple los
encierros han costado a la empresa hasta
8.000 millones de dólares y han
producido retrasos en la producción del
más reciente modelo el iPhone 14
ante la multiplicación de los muros
físicos y administrativos para muchas
personas la única manera de emigrar es a
través de rutas clandestinas sin embargo
los caminos migratorios irregulares son
evidentemente mucho más peligrosos para
la vida de las personas que los viajes
regulares según un nuevo informe de la
organización internacional de las
migraciones desde 2014 50.000 personas
han muerto mientras se desplazaban de un
país a otro para analizar la cuestión
Contamos con Edwin viales de la o&m
Edwin Buenos días empecemos analizando
el discurso respecto a la violencia en
las Fronteras del Norte global no que va
enfocado en culpar a las llamadas mafias
de tráfico de personas Pero como si
obligarán estas mafias a las personas a
migrar y a usar rutas a peligrosas es
esta una manera de la Unión Europea o de
Estados Unidos de limpiarse las manos es
decir estas mafias digamos no existirían
si las personas pudieran usar vías
migratorias legales
Muchísimas gracias
a todas y todos los que los que nos
siguen Sí en en ese sentido es es
necesario más que recalcar que sobre las
50.000 vidas perdidas durante todo el
mundo Durante los viajes migratorios que
el proyecto migrantes desaparecidos de
la hoym comenzó a documentar desde el
año 2014
no debemos perder de vista y hacer el
llamado a las al respeto del derecho
internacional y también como lo dice el
pacto mundial para la migración segura
ordenada y regular para prevenir
fallecimientos y desapariciones durante
las travesías migratorias ese en ese
sentido qué hacemos hincapié en las
obligaciones en virtud del derecho
internacional incluido el derecho a la
vida
estas deben respetarse en todo momento Y
hacemos siempre hemos desde la desde el
proyecto migrantes desaparecidos así
como desde la organización internacional
para las migraciones siempre hemos
estado a que a que se persiga a los a
los responsables de estas y así es en
ese sentido que necesitamos trabajar
juntos para prevenir y reducir muertes
priorizando las operaciones de búsqueda
y rescate así como mejorando y ampliando
las vías de migración seguras ordenadas
y regulares para asegurar para asegurar
que la gobernanza de la migración pueda
priorizar esas áreas de protección y de
seguridad de las personas en movimiento
Porque no tenemos hay mucho tiempo para
abordar además temas la cuestión es que
las políticas migratorias en el norte
global al final son una forma de
fortificar la riqueza del Norte
construida A base del expolio del sur no
un camión la política migratoria qué
aspectos debe tener en cuenta
como como el proyecto migrantes
desaparecido si la organización
internacional para las migraciones lo
han reiterado en innumerables ocasiones
sin duda debemos enfocar nuestros
esfuerzos a que las vías de migración
regulares también irregulares sean
ordenadas dignas y seguras enfatizando
anteriormente en la protección de las
personas migrantes específicamente las
personas migrantes en tránsito que
circulan estas rutas sin dudas sino
brindamos más caminos tanto de bebidas
de migración regular y de protección en
las vías de migración irregulares vamos
a tener y a seguir presenciando estos
números tan altos de personas migrantes
fallecidas y desaparecidas durante el
tránsito migratorio y Edwin no tenemos
mucho tiempo pero por ejemplo en Europa
las fronteras están vigiladas con alta
tecnología no radares sensores cámaras
térmicas vallas En qué medida la
industria militar y de la seguridad
influye en las decisiones respecto a las
políticas migratorias porque esta
industria le interesa aumentar
constantemente la inversión y que estas
políticas se dirijan a la vigilancia más
que la libre circulación
claro esto esto sin duda es esto un tema
verdad el todo el tema de la
securitización de las migraciones o de
un enfoque punitivo o de un enfoque
policial hacia el abordaje de las
migraciones sin duda que es un aliciente
y puede provocar fallecimientos y
desapariciones durante el tránsito
migratorio cuando se habla de temas
migratorios en general no solo de
personas migrantes fallecidas y
desaparecidas sin duda tanto los los
gobiernos y los diferentes entes
encargados de administrar las
migraciones en el mundo deben tener
presente que esté abortarse desde un
enfoque humanista verdad priorizando
siempre a las personas migrantes y sus
familias como centro de todos los
esfuerzos que se hagan y comprendiendo
también que la migración en muchos
sentidos entraña una oportunidad de
desarrollo para todas las naciones donde
llegan las personas migrantes que
atraviesen estas películas en rutas
Edwin viales se nos acaba el tiempo pero
muchísimas gracias por su análisis por
su trabajo y por estar con nosotros
Muchísimas gracias a usted cambiamos de
información Estados Unidos se ve
sacudido por un nuevo hecho de violencia
Armada esta vez en el estado de Virginia
la policía respondió al Llamado de
emergencia tras reportes de disparos en
un local de la tienda Walmart en la
localidad de chesapeak en su conferencia
de prensa de esta mañana las autoridades
confirmaron que el incidente dejó un
saldo de siete personas muertas
incluyendo al atacante que resultó ser
un empleado de la tienda que tras atacar
indiscriminadamente se quitó la vida
y cerramos con deportes porque juntos
esto antes de debutar en el mundial los
jugadores de Alemania posaron tapándose
la boca Como protesta ante la censura de
la FIFA la selección alemana quería
vestir el brazalete One Love en símbolo
de defensa de los Derechos Humanos
particularmente en apoyo a las personas
lgbt con más perseguidas en Qatar sin
embargo la FIFA anunció que penalizaría
con tarjeta amarilla a los futbolistas
que usaran el brazalete veamos el
comunicado de la federación alemana de
fútbol
no se trataba de hacer una declaración
política los Derechos Humanos no son
negociables Eso debería darse por
sentado pero todavía no es el caso por
eso Este mensaje es tan importante para
nosotros negarnos el brazalete es lo
mismo que negarnos una voz mantenemos
nuestra posición
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros
[Música]